Thomasina is in Knoxville
hey Thomasina how are you I'm great Dave
how are you better than I deserve
what's up :
we're kind of in I guess what you called
baby steps three B's where we're
debt-free and we have our three to six
months of expenses and we're trying to
save up to buy how great yeah and well
we can't we had a really bad year we had
a baby in May and then he only lived
about a month homeless yeah and it was
it was a hard pregnancy I had a lot of
bed rest and then our family had to be
separated because we had to go to
Cincinnati to the Children's Hospital
and I was affair for about three months
and my kids and my husband were at home
for most of that so I kind of reached a
point where now that all that's done I'm
wondering if we should take a little bit
of the money that we've saved not our
emergency fund but our money towards you
know other savings to maybe take like a
small family vacation that we connect
with our other kids I would sounds like
I went to spend that money that's okay
so hard to favorite it's okay you can
give more it's a good thing for your
family to heal honey y'all are hurting
yeah well and that's my husband I mean
you know he loves your plan here's my
plan
you're not okay you're not off my plan
doing that the only thing you're saying
is is we're gonna delay buying a house
just a little bit to take a vacation and
just spend some time hugging each other
yeah and that's that's pretty much what
what I wanted to do and we talked back
and forth and he said well you know I
don't know and there's not a step in
there no see here's the thing after baby
step three that's when gizelle intensity
stops you've got your emergency fund in
place and you're out of debt that's
where you are then you started doing
other goals okay after baby step three
other goals go back and forth you can
say for a house you can start four five
six you can do any of that coming and
there you can save up by couch and go on
vacation any that's okay and you do
your foot off the gas a little bit on
the intensity meaning you're not beans
and rice anymore okay so you can enjoy a
little bit but everything that you enjoy
we all know this means I'm some of my
other savings goals are not going to be
hit as quickly if I was saving for a car
and I go on vacation then I'm not going
by the car as quickly I'm saving for a
house I go on vacation I'm not gonna buy
a house as quick if I am saving for a
vacation and I buy a house I'm probably
not going on vacation you know so it's
just you know you're just making choices
at that point and that's where you are
so you're right dead in the middle of
our plan you're doing exactly what we
teach and all I answer here is what
would I do if I woke up in your shoes I
would delay my home purchase just a
little bit by whatever a number of
months it takes to replenish that amount
of money and I think you guys will be
spiritually emotionally relationally
well served to fill your gas tank with a
little time together away from this
crazy world that you're living in this
year thanks goodnight to say that we we
are so glad that we did your plan that
we had the money to do what we did
because actually without that our
emergency savings amount we could not
have gone to Cincinnati we could not
have funded badly and we would probably
spend the rest of our lives wondering
well what if we could have afforded to
go to that Hospital ya know where you
know where that's no regrets that's
awesome right that's awesome I'm so
sorry that you guys have been through
this heartbreaking thing yeah thanks for
calling this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]